[موسيقى]
المراه هي شخص كثير قوي وشامل عندها جميل
من كل الانواع
يعني فيها تكون بالبيت مع عائلتها بشغل
بمجتمعنا شرقي حتى قدرت توصل لمحلات مثل
الرجال كل لوحه من لوحات سبيشون المراه
عندهم خبريه من وراءهم
كان يرسم وكان ينحت فكما متاثره فيه اكيد
[موسيقى]
بلوحاته بحب المشيمه الفرح فرجي القوه
بالشخصيه من البوزيشن
مزيج من الاشكال فايتين ببعض مع ادين
من المواد اللي اشتغلت عليهم البلوريناز
يلي بيعيشوا حبيبتي السابقه يوصلوا ويقدوا
هذا الفن الكتير حلو والراقي
انا كتير اختبرت وصل على الستايل اللي عم
بشتغل عليها هلا
جربت اجمع بين فنان يلي هو فن كثير راقي
وجميل مع اللي هو شعبي ومحبوب جمال
بالتنوع جمال الانسان بشخصيته هو كيف هو
مرتاح مع حاله بحب اظهر المراه من خلال
لوحاتي بانوثتها وجميله وقوتها هي وعم
تتحدى الصعوبه بحياتها
[موسيقى]